ich entfernte mein name ist meine damen
und herren das ganze mal kennen wenn dem
einen kanal schaut auf jeden fall heute
hier kennt meistern und ihr seht her
hier ist natürlich wieder fit sein denn
und das ist verbietet gewitzelt
[Musik]
die praktisch mit mich so gar nicht
besser wie macht man diese lücke
meine damen und herren das fragt sich
keiner wahrscheinlich wir werden heute
diese pizza hinnehmen werden sie im ofen
machen und dann werden die hälfte essen
und die andere hälfte denn gegen mixa
stecken in dem video
ich fühle mich noch nicht richtig doch
kurz meine damen und herren
links da reden wir die andere hälfte der
pizza einpacken und dann werden wir
gucken wie di luca wird sagte mixa
unterm arsch tritt verfangen haben
ziemlich offen klicken hier drauf hier
klicken und betriebsrat in ober
unterhitze heizung großen vor auf 250
grad warten bis der ofen fertig geheilt
ist und in der zwischenzeit irgendwann
zeigen was christoph den spielverlauf
ich habe das team kommt schon gegeben
als ich 10 gefördert und was hast du da
aufgemacht
er liebt glaube auf den kleinbauern kann
sich nur noch um stunden oder tage
[Applaus]
insbesondere während der ofen vorheizen
würde ich sagen chris lee ist jetzt erst
mal der runde in fifa
auseinandergenommen christus gerade
pissen das heißt ich packe ihn jetzt das
elend vor bei mancity und das ist ein
feldspieler
[Applaus]
warum nicht mal eben kurz ist die pizza
ofen ist sondern nicht komplett
vorgeheizt aber dann machen wir unsere
partie noch eben zu ende war ich bin
richtig gespannt wie das schmeckt den
mixa
[Musik]
du bist der schlechteste kamera aber in
der welt ich bin ein bisschen geregnet
hat sich akhavan aussprechen
jetzt steht er jetzt für einige zeit
drin und erster zwölfter wir stehen
jetzt kurz unser tiefer zu ende und ihr
seht dann gleich das ergebnis
was gerade passiert warum es so aus ich
habe 2 0 geführt
die playoff-niederlage deutlicher
verloren glaubt ihr das bitte
eine wundervolle pitcher bei der damen
und herren wir klatschen noch ein wenig
oregano oben drauf steht kann ein
letzter zeit noch spitzer videos normale
menschen würden dass es eventuell zu
machen dass sie ein messer ich habe
keine löffel sagen sie würden das jetzt
hier durch stein die pizza und würden
sich dann sagen ja ob hier kommen wir
essen pizza jetzt aber nein wenn ich für
mich für mich für mich ein bisschen
höher mitte kennt müssen wir genau genau
da aber nein ich wollte da waren dahin
besuchen da also wieder weg das ist
beschissen wie die mutter schönling
meine damen ja wir haben damit ja schon
kurios gemacht und so weiter und sofort
packen jetzt erstmal ein stück
väterliches soll er ein christ und fühlt
sich total fight und das da rein zu
schauen das braucht die hitze aber auch
gut ist meine damen und herren
[Musik]
sie hat im partnerverbund da das hier
jetzt gerade nur irgendwie ein pulver
sirup ist pulverfass
das ist ein konversion wer jetzt noch
ganz klein bisschen wasser rein für
damit das ganze ein bisschen mehr sein
die die eventuell
[Musik]
das hat überhaupt keinen sinn gemacht
jetzt liegen die krümel einfach nur in
diesen sachen jetzt habe ich auf jeden
fall die pizza hier drin gemacht wir
haben jetzt einfach nur ein bisschen
nicht so krümelige schalke würde sagen
gerichtetes karlsruhe heute wenig noch
her
dafür nehmen wir den ausgeschalteten mix
haben und trotzdem jetzt einfach mal
alles hier raus und klatschen 2 drauf
diesmal wie das aussieht nämlich so die
dkp andere wir werden ja selbst schuld
als wärme also meine da man ja wir haben
jetzt hier das essen mehr oder weniger
fertig was jung ist das klingt einfach
ich bin echt wie pizza mix mit wasser
produkt chris wittl einmal angerufen
freund ich mach das jetzt allein mit
diesem typ kann man echt nix machen er
kann kiefer spielt kann nicht aufnehmen
alter ja jetzt ob wir uns beim nach
pizza die mixed an gemacht wurde und
naja wenn die sonne kalte pizza die wie
so holte man in die kommentare christ
ist der schlechteste kameramann der welt
danke und fifa spieler ich nehme jetzt
noch mal einen ball von 99.000 wie ich
die pizza probiere wie sowie briten
handy nicht einmal ganz neu ist dass
speck sowie werden eine pizza gegessen
hatte sie luca pizza und die so komplex
runtergeschluckt hast du nach zehn
minuten nachdem der hoch wirkt also
schmeckt echt tatsächlich nicht so gut
wie konsistent ist richtig wäre ja
genauso einfach kein snack endete das
video feiert das gerne mal mit relativ
kurzes video deutsche spontan als video
und es ist eigentlich ein bisschen
schlecht so also christen halt schlecht
wenn ich ihnen vielfalt zerstörter
supertalent ist das nicht ein dass ich
dachte bevor ich halte gar nichts so
klare nachricht dass man irgendwie ich
meine eigene
mit seinem mix attacke weil das amt von
euch ja gesagt hey wo wir das noch mal
mit pizza das schmeckt falls die andere
challenges haben sich mit der tänzer
machen soll
die kommentare am ersten zwölf dieses t
shirt mit vier weiteren produkten der
minister wie nutzer von de ist in vielen
rissen sich dass deutschland zu kaufen
weil demokratie zu kaufen das ist auf
jeden fall hier vom video jetzt kommt
das auto das ziel kombi oder das war es
jetzt hier vom video hier können jetzt
hier meinen kanal abonnieren oder hier
unten meinen job ausschenken jetzt
findet ihr zwei andere videos und wenn
ihr schon abonnent seid könnt ihr auch
die glocke klicken dann bekommen die
benachrichtigungen
[Musik]